we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219
to david p this is kind of a funny
voicemail i've been saying
in in a serious way in a genuine way
i'm not sure if matt gates gets indicted
the investigation is heating back up and
we're looking at whether he
was involved in child sex trafficking
and many other crimes um
i i don't know that he gets indicted
that's not what this caller thinks take
a listen to this
hi david i agree with virtually
everything you say
every day you know well one of the
funniest things you ever said
was at about 7 55 pm central time
on wednesday saying that
we don't know whether matt gates is
going to be indicted or not
right i don't know if he were just
hedging or what but
he's going down and there's no if ands
or buts
he's done it's just a matter of when
thanks keep up the good work yeah i was
not
hedging um if this is the united states
where we have two justice systems
and the reality is that even being an
unhinged and delusional member of
congress you're still a member of
congress and there's a certain amount of
privilege that that confers
and in all of those cases i hesitate to
assume
that there are going to be legal
consequences um
so no i was not hedging we'll see if you
are right
we'll see if you're right we will see if
he gets indicted we have a great bonus
show for you today elon musk tweeted uh
last night that tesla
is not going to continue accepting
bitcoin for tesla vehicles
and it tanked the price of bitcoin and
we are going to talk about the
implications
long term medium term and short term we
are also finding
as if you didn't know from what's been
going on for the last year
there is a trust problem when it comes
to public health
officials in the united states it's
disproportionately a problem from the
american right
as you probably would guess and we will
also talk about the sort of red line or
line in the sand
that republicans are drawing for joe
biden and they did it
in this oval office meeting that took
place yesterday so much to discuss
all of those stories and more when
producer pat joins me on today's bonus
show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com we'll see you then